(loud whoosh)
(click)
(beeping)
(cheerful piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained,
lone the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(techno music)
(synthesizer music)
- And so, as you said, we
thought we should discuss
this issue of suicide at this meeting
because it is something
which has almost certainly
had a major bearing on the
history of our own species.
I've shown a panel from
a late Roman ivory casket
which is in the British museum.
You'll see it shows two
very different examples
of humans who brought death
on themselves deliberately,
Jesus, who had no desire to stop living,
but who believed his death
would benefit all mankind,
and then Judas, who had no
thought of benefiting others
but assumed that by his own death
would at least put an end to
his own intolerable guilt.
Suicide used to be called
self murder (mumbles)
It may seem hard to associate,
harsh, I should say, to
associate suicide with murder,
but if we're looking for
the evolutionary antecedence of suicide,
I think this does in fact
get us off on the right foot.
Humans have always been murderers.
First, of course, they'd been killers
of other living beings, (mumbles) beings.
First, of course, they were
killers of animal prey for food,
and everybody in the community
would've been involved directly in that.
But they were also killers
of other human beings.
Not everyone would've had
firsthand experience of assassination,
but everyone would've known
about it and talked about it
and no doubt celebrated it.
And then the idea dawned.
Here's how psychiatrist
Erwin Stengel has put it.
"At some stage of evolution,
man must have discovered
"that he can kill not only
animals and fellow men,
"but also himself.
"It can be assumed that life
"has never since been the same for him."
But, I think it wasn't so much
the discovery that he can kill himself
that would've changed things.
It was the discovery
of what killing himself
would've amounted to,
that it would've amounted to
removing himself from the world.
A human could choose not to be.
That's why non-human animals
don't and can't commit suicide.
At any rate, even if
they do kill themselves,
as perhaps these whales did,
we shouldn't call it suicide.
That BBC headline clearly
did suggest we might.
The whales can't have been choosing death,
because so far as we know,
they haven't discovered what death means,
which humans, of course, have done.
Humans can choose death,
knowing pretty well what it
will mean for them personally.
And I think Stengel is right to say
that this discovery has
been transformative.
But we still have to ask,
transformative in just what ways?
And if we're thinking
about human evolution,
the question must be,
what affects, good or bad,
did this discovery have
on biological survival?
Other kinds of killing
can clearly be adaptive.
It's easy to explain the
survival advantages of hunting.
It's not difficult to explain
the advantages of war or homicide.
But common sense would seem to say that
self killing must be the
ultimately disadvantageous act,
a sure path to genetic oblivion.
Yet, the stark fact is that
suicide is alarmingly common
right across the world.
Someone in the United States
kills themselves every 12 minutes.
That's 120 a day.
Across the world, more
people die from suicide
than all wars and homicides combined.
We surely have to ask, then,
is suicide biologically
adaptive after all?
Well, the answer is
not going to be simple.
As I implied with my first slide,
I think we need to distinguish
two rather different kinds of suicide.
And we can call them, as Durkheim did,
altruistic suicide and egoistic suicide.
And I want to suggest they correspond
to two rather different
conceptions of what death does.
The first and simplest conception is that
death results in the
annihilation of the body.
The dead person is no longer an actor
in the physical or social world.
And corresponding to this,
when people choose to bring
about their own death,
they may be trying to make
things better for others
by giving up their own bodily presence.
Jesus died on the cross
in the hope of becoming
the savior of all mankind.
Or for a more straightforward example,
Captain Oates stumbled
out to die in the snow
in the hope of relieving the burden
for the remaining members
of Scott's polar expedition.
Altruistic suicide we can call that.
But could this kind of
suicide be adaptive?
It certainly could be,
provided it benefits the
subject's kin or social group.
In fact, it's possible that
a propensity for altruistic suicide
has been selected in humans
in rather the same way
that something like it
has been selected in the social insects.
So maybe humans are
genetically predisposed,
like ants or bees,
to sacrifice themselves
for the common good
in times of famine or plague or war,
or simply when they become too
old and decrepit to carry on.
But now let's look at
another kind of suicide,
perhaps corresponding
to a second conception
of what death does.
This is that death results in
the annihilation of the mind.
The dead person is no longer
a thinker or a feeler.
And corresponding to this conception,
when people kill themselves,
they may be trying to make
things better for themselves
by giving up on their
own conscious presence.
Judas Iscariot sought conscious oblivion
because he could not live with
his internal sense of shame.
This young couple could not bear the pain
of being forbidden by
their families to marry.
This is egoistic suicide,
and it's in many ways
the absolute opposite
of altruistic suicide.
Far from hoping to benefit others,
these self killers are motivated
primarily by self interest.
They either don't care
about the effect on others,
or sometimes they even intend
some kind of vengeance.
And whether they intend it or not,
the effects on family and
friends are often devastating.
Now, here's the problem from
an evolutionary point of view.
The fact is that 90% of
suicides are egotistical.
The World Federation for
Mental Health, for example,
reports that the most common
situations or life events
that might cause suicidal thoughts,
they aren't to do with
helping other people.
They're grief, sexual
abuse, financial problems,
remorse, rejection, relationship
breakup, and unemployment.
And anthropologist Charles MacDonald,
having surveyed suicide across
the whole world, concludes,
"A cross cultural comparison shows that
"grief over and conflict
between closely related people,
"together with sheer
physical pain and discomfort,
"cause or promote suicide more often
"than any other circumstances.
"The suicide simply
wants to stop hurting."
What the egoistic suicide wants to achieve
is basically self euthanasia.
Well, could this be adaptive?
Well, how could it possibly be?
Most egoistical suicides are young.
Across the world, it's
the second most common
cause of death amongst teenagers.
If they had not died by their own hand,
this couple hadn't died by their own hand,
they would almost certainly
have got over the hurt
and gone on to make a
success of their lives.
Egoistic suicides ruin
not only their own biological fitness,
but those of related individuals, too.
So what's going on?
Why do these tragic deaths
happen so frequently?
I think the answer is all too obvious.
Humans and humans alone understand
that by killing themselves,
they can indeed stop the hurting.
So there must be circumstances
when they may well look on
suicide as a rational act.
They feel sad or jealous
or unloved or inadequate or whatever.
These are feelings that
death will make go away.
Nothing hurts less than being dead.
In Hamlet's...
Sorry.
What's more, as the poetry of suicide
continually reminds us,
this solution to the hurting
may not only be rational.
It must often be relatively easy.
In Hamlet's notorious soliloquy,
"Who would bear the
whips and scorns of time,
"the oppressor's wrong,
the proud man's contumely,
"the pangs of despised
love, the law's delay,
"when he himself might his
quietus make with a bare bodkin?"
A dagger.
As Hamlet recognizes,
there's an unfortunate
truth about being human,
probably more true of humans
than any other animal,
and it is that hurting is part of life.
The poet (mumbles) said it explicitly.
"Everyone, every human, has
a good reason for suicide."
The philosopher Wittgenstein
once told a friend
that all his life, there
had hardly been a day
in which he hadn't thought
suicide a possibility.
More typically, among today's
American high school students,
60% say they've considered
killing themselves.
14% have thought about it
seriously in the last year,
and five percent have attempted it.
That's more than one
million students a year.
Susan Sontag has written,
"How thin the line
"between the will to live
and the will to die?"
"How about a hole," she asks,
"a really deep hole which
you put in a public place
"for general use, in Manhattan, say,
"at the corner of Seventieth and Fifth.
"A sign beside the hole reads,
'Four p.m. to eight p.m.
"'Mondays, Wednesdays, and
Fridays, suicide permitted.'
"Just that, a sign.
"Why surely, people would jump
"who had hardly thought of it before."
As I said, it's not
only rational sometimes,
but it's also very easy.
Now, this is a CARTA symposium,
and we want to understand how humans,
against all the odds perhaps,
have, in the end, survived and prospered.
And it looks as thought suicide
might have been a very significant drain
on the fitness of our ancestors.
Looks as though it might
have been a major downside
of their growing sufficiently clever
to understand their own mortality,
the sequence Ajit talked about.
It wouldn't have been dangerous
because they feared death,
but because they were attracted to it.
But surely, natural selection, then,
ought to have sorted this out long ago.
Why haven't humans evolved to have
better innate defenses against suicide
built into their mind?
Of course, Ajit thinks they have.
When reality becomes too much to bear,
people simply deny it.
But, I confess, I don't see
this working as he says,
or at least not in these contexts.
I see no evidence that humans
have evolved to have any
kind of natural immunity
to what I've called the lure of death.
To the contrary, I'm led to think
that in the past, if not today,
suicide might've spread like measles
in an unprotected population.
In fact, measles is a surprisingly
alarmingly apposite analogy,
because the suicide meme
happens to be highly infectious.
It jumps from mind to mind,
resulting in the well
documented phenomenon
of copycat suicides.
As Durkheim wrote, "Suicide
is very contagious.
"There is the well known
story of the 15 patients
"who hung themselves in
swift succession in 1772
"from the same hook in a dark
passage of the hospital."
Suicide contagion has been
dubbed the Werther Effect
after the hero of Goethe's novel,
The Sorrows of Young Werther.
In the novel, Werther kills himself
after falling hopelessly in
love with a married woman.
Following its publication in 1774,
there where literally hundreds
of copycat deaths in Germany.
Recent research has confirmed
just how strong the effect is.
Every time a celebrity suicide
is given exposure in a newspaper
or TV, the copycats follow.
It's estimated that Marilyn
Monroe's death in August, 1962
was responsible for 200 actual
suicides within a month.
After a popular South Korean
actress hung herself in 2008,
suicides jumped 66% that month,
with young hanging victims
accounting for most of the increase.
But 66%, that's nothing.
There are some parts of the world today
where rates of suicide are 10
times the average elsewhere,
and this turns out to be
largely to do with copying.
Among these happy people
on the island of Palawan
in the Philippines,
MacDonald's research has documented
waves of suicide spreading
through small villages.
The question becomes, then,
how prevalent was suicide
amongst our ancestors,
say, 50,000 years ago?
I don't think any paleo-anthropologist
has ever thought to ask.
But assuming humans must by then
have acquired an understanding of death,
we can be quite sure there were suicides.
And let's remember, times were harsh.
In the icy climate of central Europe,
there would've been plenty
to be unhappy about.
I think we should allow the possibility
that there were indeed recurrent plagues
of egoistic suicide,
with rates topping anything we see today.
Well, if this is true,
if there were these plagues of suicide,
and I think it's a genuine
scientific possibility,
what could and did bring it under control?
Assuming humans have never evolved
adequate natural immunity to suicide,
the antidote, whatever it
was, must have been cultural.
And here I have to say
the picture is complicated
and not well researched,
but at least some of the
cultural barriers to suicide
are indeed in plain view.
In historical times, religious authorities
have regularly issued
anathemas against it.
Medieval Christianity decreed
that self murderers would go to Hell.
Victims would not be
given a decent burial,
but rather be buried at
the crossroads at night
with a stake through the heart.
In many countries, attempted suicide
has also been made a crime
under the common law.
In the United Kingdom,
attempted suicide was not
decriminalized until 1961.
In the 10 years pre-1961,
there were 6,000 prosecutions.
5,400 attempted suicides were found guilty
and imprisoned or fined.
It was common practice
in the 1950s in Britain
to have a policeman sitting at the bedside
of an unconscious patient
in accident and emergency
waiting to interview the
patient when he or she revived.
There have also been attempts
to limit the spread of the suicide meme
by limiting exposure to it.
In Europe, after the effect
of Goethe's book became apparent,
it was soon banned in several countries.
In Germany, it was even forbidden
to dress like young Werther
in blue coat and yellow trousers.
In most countries today, there
are strict press guidelines
intended to play down
the reporting of suicide
to keep it off the front page
and to avoid sensational headlines.
So we've had suicidal acts being punished
and information about them suppressed.
Do these measures actually work?
Well, yes, I think there's reason to think
they actually probably do.
Or at any rate, there's no
reason to think that they don't.
But surely more focused
methods ought to work, as well.
In place of punishment or censorship,
why not try to fight meme with meme?
Why not oppose a destructive mind virus
with a redemptive one?
What should we tell people
who want to kill themselves?
The English priest Chad Varah
founded The Samaritans in 1954,
a group dedicated to talking suicides down
with words of reassurance.
The message, "There is hope,"
may seem to verge on the banal,
but in fact it's the one message
we can give with confidence.
Research shows that in
nine cases out of 10,
the hurt isn't going to last.
Here's Daniel Gilbert,
who already Ajit quoted,
author of the book Stumbling on Happiness,
"Few of us can accurately gauge
"how we will feel tomorrow or next week.
"We expect to feel devastated
if our spouse leaves us
"or if we get passed over
for a big promotion at work,
"but when things like that do happen,
"it's soon, 'She never was right for me,'
"or, 'Actually I needed more
free time for my family.'
"People mistakenly expect such blows
"to be much more devastating
than they turn out to be."
In a sense, it's a pessimism virus.
We think things are
going to be really bad,
so bad that we can do
nothing but end our lives,
but the message of this
research, I suppose,
is don't jump now,
because it's not what your
future self would choose.
But have we had to wait
for a Harvard psychologist
to tell us this?
No, thankfully not.
The message is implicit,
presumably for a good reason,
in much of the hand-me-down
wisdom of our old cultures,
in stories and songs
and proverbs and so on.
And the good news for our
species is that on the whole,
with too many dreadful exceptions,
hope can and does win out.
And I think that's what basically
has taken us out of the Ice
Ages to where we are today.
Okay.
This is the closing talk of the symposium.
We've heard a lot today about
what a bad thing death is.
We haven't actually heard much about
what a good thing life is,
which is in the end, of
course, the whole point.
So I'll finish with a passage
from George Borrow's
autobiographical novel, Lavengro,
which echoes some of the things
actually Sheldon was saying.
As Borrow tells it, he's
been reading Goethe,
and it's an autobiography,
I think he had been,
and he's toying with the idea of suicide.
He gets into conversation
with a Romany Gypsy, Jasper,
whom he's befriended on his travels.
I'll read a passage from the novel.
"What is your opinion of death?"
said I as I set down beside him.
Jasper replies, "Life is sweet, brother.
"Who would wish to die?"
"I would wish to Die," says Borrow.
"You talk like a fool," says Jasper.
"Wish to die indeed.
"There's night and day,
brother, both sweet things.
"Sun, Moon, and stars,
brother, all sweet things.
"There's the wind on the heath, brother.
"If I could only feel that,
I would gladly live forever."
Well, this painting is in fact
called The Wind on the Heath.
And I think the good news is
that we've all been there.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat synthesizer music)